hi I'm Kyra hi I'm Stephanie hey I'm
Nick I'm caught yet hey I'm Kevin hello
say your name Jackie and today we're
gonna be drawing baby you two matchups
based on the wheel yes it's gonna be fun
will it go ahead and spin the wheels do
it okay I can do that I can do that God
okay whatever I don't care
Shrek is fine is great oh okay okay oh
that's gonna be terrifying that's we're
really cute baby Ursula
well she she must have made a cute baby
[Music]
okay I'll do that when you do shrink
we can't switch why mule has spoken why
can't we I want to draw Totoro
all right you want to switch yes I'll do
Shrek you do Totoro yeah okay sure so
we're very weel we're bending the rules
and we don't care because nobody who can
tell us not to do that Nick how do you
normally work I don't know my mind just
went blank when he said go oh no the
other a game plan think uh definitely
gonna mash up the UM the octopus element
with kind of a cute little baby yeah
mine looks like Pikachu it's supposed to
look like Totoro oh my god really yeah
so Katya what the heck is gonna be your
approach so I'm literally just taking
like Hulk's body and putting baby you at
his head on top of it the cool thing
about shrek and baby yoda is they're
both wearing kind of
burlap sack kind of get ups but I
haven't watched the mandalorian but why
is baby Yoda a dress like that here's
the story of baby Yoda okay baby Yoda is
not actually baby Yoda baby Yoda is the
child that's how they refer to him on
the show and he is a baby of Yoda's
species but not specifically Yoda that
feels like a spoiler also he's like 50
years old oh yeah he's like 50 years old
I knew I hated baby Yoda why do you hate
baby Yoda he's terrible look at him what
he looks like he's got something up his
sleeve I am a nerd I know all things
Star Wars Star Trek Lord of the Rings
Harry Potter anything else you could
think of as nerdy I know it is kind of
starting to look like a gremlin yeah
trying to figure out how to resolve the
hood with the ears oh they could stick
out you can make holes for them and they
can stake out holes I like that idea
that's a good idea I am curious to see
how you are going to reconcile baby
Yoda's huge ears of a toda Rose little
ears I'm not gonna do okay
what do you think about that Kevin well
it's just that part of what makes baby
Yoda so cute is his giant ears so I sure
hope your Totoro is cute like right now
I keep it very loose very rough I'm just
thinking about shapes and and then just
thinking about ideas and then trying to
rough them in and as I as I like
something like even like with this hair
that I'm drawing right now I like it so
I'm starting to kind of finesse it and
bring it more into focus
is that your Yoda I'm trying
what does your sound like I don't sounds
like Frank Oz and he also puts the
subject of his sentences at the end of
his sentences so draw taro I went mmm
drawing Shrek I must how you feeling I
love him I just colored his eyeball I
hold whatever they are and it's really
it's looking real cute it's really
coming together he's looking he's
looking real angry and I think I'm gonna
use that like baby Yoda like like pose
like that the teacup pose all right I'm
not giving him tea to sip I'm making him
hold and onion tea to sit yeah the big
baby Yoda meme is him sipping tea oh
yeah they're saying that he's the new
sipping tea mean a lot of what I draw is
sort of that vintage EPA mid-century
modern little golden book style yeah I'm
very flattered when I was at Disney
I was called sort of like the modern
Mary Blair oh my god Mary Blair was a
visual development artist at Disney
around 1940s 50s 60s she had a huge
influence on shows and rides and movies
so if you've seen Alice in Wonderland if
you know it's a small world than you
know Mary Blair this looks like somebody
entered baby Yoda into like a beauty
pageant I don't really like it I love
that idea so it's I mean beauty pageants
are like drag for babies and she is like
a drag queen
yes that was based off of divine well a
my baby Shrek looks like me that's on
brand yep I typically work using a lot
of multiply and color dodge oh really so
I use multiply a lot which tends to
break my colors down and I use color
dodge to bring them up I'm painting
sonic blue like that both of our
villains are kind of purply themed to
find
I'm moving on to color shrek is kind of
a pea green which is kind of gross gross
it's like a swamp yeah he's like a swamp
green what do you think is the hardest
thing for young artists to master early
in their careers I think the thing that
I've been seeing the most about young
artists and even even older artists too
is not comparing yourself to other
people 100% agree I did it all the time
when I was in school I was like oh my
gosh look at all these people that are
amazing yeah I went to school with some
super super talented people and it was
just it was terrifying
you know the thing that I tell my
students nowadays as I tell them if
you're drawing and the drawing that you
do today is better than the drawing you
did last week or a year ago or whatnot
you're progressing as an artist that
means you're getting better yeah all
right are you done I'm done I think mine
looks like me but I also think it looks
like Shrek and baby Yoda so it's a
triple mash-up that's pretty that you
you did more than they asked for you did
more than what the wheel asked for and
the wheel is he's hard to please what do
you think Miyazaki would say if he saw
yours Miyazaki saw this he'd probably go
[Music]
Rocky impression not he doesn't speak
much English I think it's kind of cool
how about you um I feel pretty good
about mine um I like how cute it is I'm
happy about how cute it is do you think
Miyazaki would want to be under off oh
absolutely not a hundred percent No
oh my god oh my goodness oh I love her
earrings this is my baby now I love the
makeup the mole like Ursula is in there
and she's like ready to mess some stuff
up as a little baby Yoda oh my god
this is so adorable it's gritty he looks
like he's about to punch me
he's like gosh Luke did like like a full
painting did I like 30 minutes I didn't
have enough time to do anything
interesting
like wow oh my God look at that
what oh you like just put Craig's head
onto a tiny baby body and gave him huge
I mean it's not it's not a bad drawing I
just hate it is it cursed yes it's
cursed
why would uh you're super cute thank you
as always
mm-hmm you did a great job of
incorporating the kind of burlap sack
but you made it like fancy you gave him
like a fur collar it looks like a fur
collar yeah no reference I use oh yeah
yeah it looks like a it looks like a
nice little little Chanel coat and you
went with the small ears I did I didn't
I know how to in between it so now
they're just small it looks like a
little bun you know that's Bonnie to me
[Music]